yeah this is a big deal i know i've been
working on the questions all weekend
long i'm told that nothing is off limits
nothing nothing is offline right she can
ask anything she wants
the couple really want this to be an
interview in which they can sit down and
tell their
side of the story up until now we've
heard versions of their story
through the voices and the retelling of
other people this is their first
opportunity to sit down and talk about
the past year
in their own words it's a very real
thing to be going through behind the
scenes
i'm told the intention is not to hurt or
upset anyone in the royal family they
want to be respectful particularly
to the queen but it is important to the
couple that they
finally now have a chance to put their
side of their story across
in their own words we are told that this
is going to be a wide-ranging
interview and that nothing is off limits
megan will discuss motherhood
her philanthropy work what it was like
marrying into the royal family
and inevitably they're going to be
talking about what it was like to leave
the royal family
i'm sure that we're going to see her
discuss in some detail at least her
relationship with her father
um oprah's going to have to ask those
questions if this is going to be
the sit-down interview then it needs to
be all-encompassing there is very much a
desire to
talk about the future but also to
reflect on some of the past because it
brings me great sadness
that it has come to this the decision
that
i have made for my wife and i to step
back
is not one i made lightly but as far as
this goes
there really was no other option the
fact that they are a year into their new
lives in la
i it was only a matter of time before
they were going to sit down with someone
and who were they going to sit down well
oprah winfrey of course was the obvious
choice for the couple she's a friend she
is a neighbor
but she also has a reputation for really
getting to the heart of her subjects
and getting people to open up she is
someone on their inner circle and
clearly megan
and harry both feel comfortable about
sitting down with oprah for this
no holds barred interview of course
until the interview
airs we don't know how it's going to be
received by the royal family
yes it will send alarm bells ringing at
the palace historically
these sit-down interviews that the
royals have given have only ever
backfired of course megan and harry will
be hoping that this is a success for
them
now that they are non-working members of
the royal family harry megan aren't
obliged to run anything they do past the
palace this is their choice
and they didn't need to run it past
anyone at the palace in fact i think the
first the palace heard about it
was when the press got wind of it i hope
that helps you understand
what it had come to that i would step my
family back
from all i have ever known just take us
to take a step forward
into what i hope can be a more peaceful
life there is a lot of talk that now
we are coming up to that year
anniversary of them leading britain
that final severance of the divorce is
going to take place there is speculation
that
harry and megan will lose their official
royal patronages
as they embark on a completely
independent life of the royal family
this i'm told is their moment to sit
down to tell the truth
[Music]
you